even if you've never encountered a black
widow spider or a poisonous dart frog
you instinctively think just by looking
at them hey maybe I shouldn't with that
[Music]
thing like music color is a complex and
subjective experience it has a powerful
influence over our behavior and a very
strong effect on how we feel color is
the most important factor as to whether
or not we will buy something whether
we're aware of it or not we are being
influenced and even manipulated by color
all of the time Beyond marketing and in
far less creepy ways one of my favorite
things about color is how I can tell a
story and films are great at this Wes
Anderson is a master at doing this and
you can spot his color voice in every
film that he's made color also tells us
how to feel and this opening Montage
from the film up is a fantastic example
of that and if you didn't cry during
this scene you might be a robot